[Music]
a few minutes outside banff alberta
there's a serpentine lake
lake minnewanka it's a gorgeous lake
perfect for day trips
boating hiking camping and even scuba
diving
it's actually a natural lake but not as
it currently exists
the outlet has been damned three times
first
a small timber dam was constructed for
flood control in 1895
replaced with a hydroelectric dam in
with the final and current damond
causeway finishing construction
in 1941. cumulatively these damning
projects have raised the surface of the
lake over 25 meters
flooding the original shoreline a small
settler town
and dozens of ancient stoney nakoto work
sites
a number of these old ruins which you
can see marked by boys
are popular cold water diving
destinations
and if you wanted to demonstrate the
curve of the earth it would be an ideal
place to do it
so you can see that the water
clearly has no curvature
add the water surface is completely flat
wait back up why are we demonstrating
the curve of the earth
about five six years back i got really
into flat earth theories
not as a believer but as an observer i
would check in on them and watch their
documentaries and read through their
memes and infographics and
generally have a jolly good time poking
fun at them on twitter
i was at one point building up to making
a video on the subject when known moon
criminal h bomber guy produced his video
on flat earth
and due to youtube community standards
and bylaws section 7.2.1
the paratemporal exclusion clause aka
reviewer dibs i had to shelve my plans
for a year in change
the thing that really spurred me on
originally was a specific flat earth
video i came across
one evening in 2017 flat earth proof
one the level now
this video is not particularly
noteworthy in the scope
of flat earth videos it's an hour and a
half compilation of short videos stolen
from a different
smaller flat earth youtube channel and
it runs through
all the normal flat earth tropes such as
not understanding gravity
failing to appreciate just how big
mountains really are and
generally being really bad at math there
was no basis for such an explanation
other than the desperate attempt to
excuse away these critical findings
but there is one thing that makes it
special
the host of the video does some original
research by going out to the shore of
lake minnewanka
okay here we are at lake minnewanka
in alberta thing is
lake minnewanka is only 90 minutes away
from my house
the flat earth is in my own backyard
so hypothetically if i did want to
debunk a forgotten
four-year-old flat earth video that
originally had a couple hundred views
i could conceivably jump in my car on a
clear day
drive out to lake minnewanka and set up
a camera with
the longest lens i own but that'd be
[Music]
ludicrous
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here we are at lake minnewanka
in alberta and as you can see
we're just
less than a foot above the water surface
here
and if we zoom in across the lake
the coastline across the lake
clearly comes into focus
so you can see that the water clearly
has
no curvature
and the water surface is completely flat
okay so let's talk quick about the
challenges involved in this kind of
proof
going out to minnewanka was actually a
really good
pick because the lake is really long
there's a lot of shoreline where you
have several kilometers of unobstructed
line of sight
far enough for the curve of the earth to
be meaningful
while the mountainous terrain provides a
clearly identifiable shore on the other
side
and while the lake is long enough to get
these really far lines of sight
it's not big enough to get any
meaningful tidal movements
so all the waves are just from wind
blowing across the surface you don't get
the big
roiling surges that you see in the ocean
from the dam that makes up the southwest
bank of lake minnewanka to the rock
slide on the far
shore where elmer canyon meets the lake
you have a line of sight of seven
kilometers about
four and a third miles which is far
enough that the earth curves away
around three and a half meters or 11
feet
this is a kind of perfect distance it's
close enough for objects on the far side
to still be identifiable
while being a significant enough curve
that the obstruction
is perceptible if we punch a bunch of
numbers into a curvature calculator we
can see that going from just
barely above the water surface to an
average adult height
the height of a hidden object at seven
kilometers goes from 3.46 meters
to only 0.4 meters this means that
something the size of a tree
at or near the water level of the lake
should appear
just about whole when viewed from a
standing position but then be visibly
obscured
by getting down to the surface of the
water so the experiment should be pretty
simple
pick a landmark on the far side of the
lake and record it at the same focal
length and distance from a couple
different elevations above the water
surface
personally i think that his footage does
in fact show
the far shore disappearing behind the
curve it's just very difficult to tell
because the resolution is so low so
let's say
for the sake of argument that an obscure
flat earth video is still under your
skin
after several years what do you do well
obviously you throw a bunch of gear into
the car drive out to the mountains
set up on the side of the lake and spend
an hour aiming at a tree on the far
shore keeping in mind that if you want
to persuade flat earthers
then you need to eliminate as much
ambiguity as possible
so make sure to include an identifiable
landmark in the shots to make it easy to
pinpoint exactly where you're standing
and where you're looking everything gets
documented where was the camera sitting
on the beach approximately how high
above the surface
even screen caps of where gps says
you're standing
you get the footage home import it tweak
the scale to make sure that objects are
the same size on screen
and line it all up with a unified
horizon there you go
the tree disappears below the horizon of
the lake
easy the earth is round
yeah but if i were into flat earth you
know what i'd point out
that last frame the one that's right
above the surface of the water
it's really hazy because it turns out
that on a 30 degree day there's gonna be
a lot of vapor coming off the surface of
the lake
and at water level you're trying to look
straight through
seven kilometers of the stuff and having
such a stark air temperature gradient
right at the surface of the water it
increases atmospheric refraction
resulting in the mirage effect that
allows the pebble beach to
occasionally be somewhat visible despite
intersecting the tree that it's below so
you know a flat earther could just
dismiss
all of this as just heat coming off the
water
and the shots are all locked off and
disconnected there's no
continuity who knows what shenanigans
you can get up to when the camera cuts
plus i mean look at it all that
straightening and zooming in post
how can anyone trust that the camera is
set to what you say
it's set to so jump back in the car two
days later when it's partly cloudy and
15 degrees cooler
there's a lot more chop from the wind
but the waves are short
it's still a lake we're not dealing with
big ocean swells
importantly there's functionally no
visible vapor coming off the surface of
the water
and this time you make sure to bring the
jib so you can smoothly go from standing
to the surface of the water in a single
motion and
[Music]
we checked the footage when we were out
there on the lake
we we looked at it on the camera just to
make sure that we got something and so
we we knew that we got it but but
getting home and and seeing it
in in this
detail like this level of clarity it's
it
honestly it's kind of affecting me um
you know you can see this
just with the naked eye when you're out
there on the beach you can
pick a thing on the far shore and just
kind of look at it
and then like crouch down and get like
really close to the water surface and
you see it
kind of you know get get occluded but
but
seeing it at this magnitude
it it feels
profound
[Music]
it's a shame it's not enough
the unfortunate reality of debunking
flat earth is that it's largely futile
at least for the actual purpose of
persuading flat earthers this isn't me
saying that we shouldn't do it and there
are in fact a bunch of reasons why we
should
i mean first of all it's a lot of fun to
debunk flat earth
proving that the earth is round is one
of those exercises that's not
quite trivial it does take some amount
of effort but
it's not that hard either it's in a
really sweet spot
a lot of it can be done from home with
some focused research or spending the
time to do the math properly
and other experiments just require
living near a relatively big lake
and yeah we should admit that it's a lot
of fun to debunk a claim like this
another example from anchorage alaska is
mount mckinley
at 130 miles away on the ball earth the
320 foot summit should be leaning away
from the observer
and almost half covered by 9220 feet
of curved earth but just like mount
forwarder
mount mckinley is always seen standing
straight up
and visible from base to summit okay we
know the distance from anchorage to
denali it's 129 miles which
yes should create a hidden target height
of 9000 feet
and denali should be leaning away from
the observer
but earth has a radius of about 3965
miles
and denali is over 20 000 feet tall
so at minimum 11 000 feet of the
mountain should still be visible
leaning away from the observer by a
trivial 1.8 degrees
like as a controlled example here are
two pyramids in blender
one of them is leaning away from the
camera by 1.8 degrees
can you tell which one and the base of
the mountain cluster on the anchorage
side is 40 miles closer to the observer
than the peak
and is 1600 feet above sea level so
the end result is less of the
proportional mass of the mountain is
hidden
by the curve of the earth than it feels
like if you're just looking at the
numbers
also you can't actually see the true
base of the mountain from anchorage
it just feels like you can because you
can see so
much of the mountain plus to get a
really good look at the mountain you're
probably going to have to find some
higher elevation yourself just to
see over buildings trees hills and other
nearby obstructions
which will further increase your line of
sight over the curve
like just in this example here we can
see over the tallest buildings in
anchorage
so the photograph was taken from at
least 300 feet up
bottom line is you can see denali from
very far away because it's really
really really really big
and it was the pyramid on the right that
was leaning away
that's fun to figure out it's the same
kind of satisfaction you get from
solving a math puzzle or something like
this claiming
that there are no self-pointing
compasses that's a fantastic starter for
talking about how we privilege the
global north in science in small but
consistent ways
via maps or yes things like compasses
because like every compass is a
self-pointing compass
but we don't frame it that way we paint
one arm of the compass red and say that
that points north and we talk about
compasses
in that term we say it's like oh this
indicates
north even though what it's really doing
is it's aligning itself with the
directionality of the
magnetic field so it's indicating both
north and south it's indicating polarity
and points towards both poles
simultaneously
but that's not the language that we use
to describe it and driving out to the
mountains with a trunk full of camera
gear
spending an afternoon sitting on the
shore of a gorgeous lake
that's just a lot of fun and you get a
chance to show everyone something
really cool about our world and
sometimes flat earthers are just
hilarious all the movies about space and
all the other movies they all in some
way
push that globe model the globe the
image of the beast
heliocentrism has nothing to do with
science
the idea that the sun is the center was
thought up
by occultists jesuit priests
the vatican it's not has nothing to do
with science
and they say that the earth orbits the
sun
going 66 600 miles an hour and if you
google
how fast does this the earth orbit the
sun
they tell you 18.5
miles per second
hold on take it ahead and that's
honestly the frame that most flat earth
debunking lives within
the nonsense claims of flat earthers
forming the starting point of a process
of puzzle solving
or a discussion of geography or a mini
lesson in optics
because at the end of the day flat
earthers
are not available to be persuaded
so we do need to be really careful while
we're out here this is
this is bear country not just bear
country this is serious bear country so
we got
we got the bear bells we got bear spray
and the thing is is that right now we're
at the tail end
of uh their fall like
feeding season when they get really uh
when they when they stock up for winter
and
uh around the lake and up into a couple
of these canyons here
is a prime growing area for
for the bison berries that they
that they eat to do that and at this
point
we should talk about what flat earth is
like what flat earth
really is nominally flat earth is a
belief that the earth
isn't a globe but is actually flat a
fact that is being kept from
us meaning normal people by a nebulous
powerful
them for nefarious inscrutable purposes
this is where profiles of flat earth
tend to stop which
is fair it's a reasonable summary for
most purposes
i want to go beyond that though because
i think it's worth considering
that the shape of the earth might
actually be the least
important belief of flat earth flat
earth is a syncretic
biblical belief that is both evangelical
and apocalyptic
that's a lot of jargon what does that
mean syncretism
is effectively a process of creating new
texts out of the desirable parts
of old texts regardless of the previous
relationship between those texts
syncretism is saying two different books
both mention dragons or use the word
dragon or call an antagonist the great
dragon
so they must be referring to the same
thing they're talking about the exact
same great dragon
and if we cobble together all these
different stories of dragons
we can uncover the truth about dragons
finger pointing at the now defunct nasa
will then turn to finger pointing at the
government who directed the whole thing
this is where we run into some dangerous
ground involving things like
the ark of the covenant the holy grail
and the ring of power
as a syncretic belief system you'll find
all sorts of fragmentary elements lifted
from seemingly disconnected and often
contradictory sources
forced into something resembling
agreement
and this spans various legitimate
ancient texts as well as modern myths
angels giants world trees and modern
conspiracy staples like
mk ultra the kennedy assassination and
aliens
all have a spot at the table in some
corner or another
let me cut to the chase i'm talking
about the no forests on flat earth
theory right we see the evidence for
these
trees or as i call them the silica
pillars
all around us they're in movies they're
in books
and but look at this this is evidence
you know society and the world at large
would try to have you believe
that this is just erosion additionally
support will be teased out of nearly any
sacred text that is sufficiently
mythological or
abstract such that it can be stripped of
context or
interpreted hyperliterally or in some
way be made to agree
with the construction of their reality
funny the people that will accept the
fact that the anunnaki
star creatures came to this planet will
avoid
fallen angels like a plague they
actually go quite far back and are found
in the teachings of many mystic
traditions such as catholicism and greek
and babylonian mystery schools
also i should note that i'm specifically
framing this as a syncretic
biblical belief not strictly christian
because while the modern flat earth
movement clearly has deep roots in the
social
and lexical traditions of american
christianity
the actual theological doctrines of
christianity are largely
absent or secularized while the bible is
a core text and many flat earth
evangelists are unambiguously christian
the wider flat earth movement is largely
only
interested in the parts concerning the
creation
and end of the world in essence modern
flat earth
is an offshoot of christianity where
jesus is a secondary figure
and the primary theological concern is
the true nature of the physical world
its origin and its destiny but also
all of that lives side by side with pop
culture egyptology
mystical gnosticism and
i i don't know what you'd call it uh
esoteric
fictionalism the the belief that the
fantastical worlds of pop culture
are a warped or coded reflection of the
true world
and this is where we get stories like
jack and the beanstalk where he climbs
up this pillar
and he ends up in the land of the titans
or the giants right
it's chaotic and inconsistent because
there is no central authority no
unique unifying texts so you'll find
different commentators that take any
given point to
more or less extreme conclusions which
can make it difficult to talk about the
movement as a whole
but there are elements that remain
consistent
across the field of flat earth texts the
world is flat and
they are hiding that fact from you
because a flat earth
would be irrefutable proof that we live
in a divine fishbowl and thus
god is real this is important because
again
they are evangelical and apocalyptic
this means first that orthodoxy is
considered a spiritual necessity
that there is a universal divine moral
right and wrong and all are held to
account for the rightness of their
beliefs
as a result it is the imperative of the
believers to make sure as many people
are believers as possible
because there are consequences for not
believing
to be clear and i can't stress this
enough
do not start conversations with the word
flat earth you may note already that
this is
clearly setting up an adversarial
relationship between flat earthers
and everyone else as anyone who denies
flat earth or works to debunk it
is not just presenting alternative
evidence of the way the world works
but is impeding proof of god
the second critical meaning is a belief
that there is an impending
literal end to the world this end will
occur at some unknown point in the
future but that point is always
soon many flat earthers subscribe to the
pop culture version of a biblical
apocalypse but it doesn't actually
feature
super heavily for the most part with
most kind of just skipping past the
details to the part where
god shows up and proves that they're
right it is difficult to understate the
impact on long-term planning the
support for policies and politicians
that comes from the belief that at some
point in the next generation or two
god will just personally show up and
wrap up humanity like a board game being
packed back into its box
a critical component of flat earth's
world view is the baked in idea of
opposition
the enemy the them isn't merely another
group with different ideas of what's
best for the world or a different set of
motivations that may or may not
intersect with the well-being of others
they are actively seeking harm
this is in a way the immune response of
paranoid conspiratorial thought
it creates an impenetrable counter to
any conflict
any disagreement any counter-argument is
clearly manufactured by an opposition
that isn't merely indifferent to truth
but
actively knowingly suppressing it
i wanted to take a look at this
dimension of flat earth because two of
my peers and friends
h bomber guy and philosophy tube have
done videos on flat earth
and well i don't think they are wrong i
think their assessment of flat earth
is incomplete both of their videos
function
like many others by taking flat earth as
a jumping off point to discuss
intersecting concepts of philosophy and
science and sociology
and that's great they're good videos
the idea that philosophy tube brings up
that discussions of science
are a rhetorical exercise influenced by
the social context that they are had
within
and the idea that flat earthers are
unpersuaded by
conventional rhetoric or perhaps
persuaded into flat earth
by unconventional rhetoric is one that
we have grappled with in making this
it's an extremely relevant concept none
of those have
anything whatsoever to do with the
evidence they just
all note a failure to be rhetorically
persuaded
harry goes to great lengths to give flat
earthers the benefit of the doubt
carefully isolating the very specific
belief
that the world is flat and addressing
the anxieties
that specifically narrowly come up with
the ontology of the physical world
you're right to feel that something is
wrong
because something is wrong just maybe
keep looking for the source of what that
thing is because
the earth is not flat on the surface
flat earthers
share many of the same anxieties as the
rest of us
they are worried about the power
structures that have immense influence
over our lives
these systems that shape the information
we have access to
and the shared fictions that society
operates on
like money and rent but there is perhaps
an overwillingness to treat them as
harmless cranks as though we can start
from their shared frustrations with the
world and just
gently nudge them in a more sensible
direction
these common anxieties are a shared
coordinate that is i think
far more superficial than we would want
it to be
because while we're all worried and
skeptical of what people in power are
doing
flat earthers have very very different
ideas
about who's in power and what they're
trying to do with it
flat earthers are not otherwise empty
vessels who believe
one kooky thing they believe that thing
because it suits their purposes flat
earthers
have an agenda the end goal of
conspiratorial beliefs is to simplify
reality by attributing the high chaos
state of the world
to a singular active force or group
opposed by an equally singular solution
indoctrination is the way they run this
world it's the way that they keep their
lie going
it's the way that they have passed their
lie along as science when it is nothing
more than a belief
they have a biased foundation built on a
lie and now they know they're stuck
their anxiety is that the world has
become too complex
that too many things are changing and
that science and progressivism
are actively malicious elements working
to obstruct the true nature of god
most people don't actually believe flat
earth because they were persuaded by
shoddy evidence or they found
other evidence to be less persuasive
about the nature of the physical world
they do so because it says something
they already believe about the nature of
the social world flat earth is a thing
people want to believe
because if it were true it would be
irrefutable proof
of everything else they believe flat
earth is a system that selectively
delegitimizes power structures
and does so by working backwards flat
earth insists that you're being lied to
by
them typically gays liberals or jews in
order to obfuscate the existence of god
and are thus not merely an opponent of
their isolationist
xenophobic policies but an enemy of
righteousness itself
heliocentrism is simply modern day sun
worship
masquerading as a science they are not
trying to
explain the world they are attempting to
unexplain it because the explanations
the
real explanations have become
inconvenient to their politics
and while there is a shared sense of the
world being
out of whack the diagnosis and
prescriptions
are very different i don't think it's
actually possible to isolate flat earth
from the reactionary current that it
swims in
and i don't know for some reason in 2020
i found myself with a lot less patience
for people who engage in performative
rejection of empathy and evidence
on that note who wants to guess how flat
earthers feel about covet masks
anyone that is voluntarily wearing a
mask at this stage
is a mindless drone who couldn't think
for themselves if their
life depended on it the deeper more
critical issue is in the information
landscape that has given rise to new
faith movements like flat earth
we are in an extremely low trust media
environment
as a product of decades of active
sabotage combined with a corporate
capitalist environment that prioritizes
the interests of the wealthy or
blindly pursues metric-driven success
models like
engagement there are a lot of legitimate
reasons to distrust the media
to see them as at best spineless in the
face of disinformation
or as outright collaborators and
profiteers
the prevalence of legitimate reasons for
distrust legitimate
anxieties for the future creates an
ideal environment for groups like flat
earth
who peddle a simplistic us versus them
model of the universe
so a couple days ago i'm
tracking down some uh
flat earth stuff and i find myself
watching
a live stream a flat earth live stream
that's mostly um
they're just watching basically reruns
of conference videos and
and other stuff and other flat earth
stuff and i
i make the mistake of uh talking in chat
that i mentioned this experiment that i
did and i don't you know come in as
as a like aggressive disbeliever but i'm
like hey
so like the video that we were watching
the video that they were watching
was one where the guy
says like okay like there's these
experiments you can do like you can
try these yourself and you can
get the results and you can see the
results you can see that there is no
curve
and
so i'm like hey a couple weeks ago
i went out to a really really big lake
and i did this test you know i
i replicated these tests that they're
saying to do
and you know like boats in the far
shore like disappeared behind the curve
and and they say oh well you know it
must have been
it must have been big you know water
swells it was
it was swells in the waves
and i'm like nah this is a
this is a long lake but it's not a big
lake like this the water was
like really calm you know there were
no swells and they're like well you know
boats aren't that big they can they can
hide themselves in their own wake
i'm like well no this is like a tour
boat it's like four meters tall
and and we go through like kind of a
bunch of other things where they're just
like oh well was it this and and it was
all stuff that i had controlled for
it was all stuff that i had anticipated
and factored in
and the one guy
is just like well
you must have done it wrong you did
something wrong
pray about it and do it again
[Laughter]
and and i just think it's like
you just told me to pray the curve away
okay so how did flat earth actually gain
traction
like okay there's a lot of different
conspiracy theories out there there's a
lot of world views both
legitimate and scams that have the same
you have been lied to pitch so
why flat earth modern flat earth was
essentially created by content
algorithms trying to maximize retention
and engagement by serving user
suggestions for
things that are effectively
incrementally more concentrated versions
of the thing
they were already looking at bizarre
cranks peddling random theories are an
aspect of civilization that has
always been with us so it was inevitable
that they would end up on youtube
but the algorithm made sure they found
an
audience these systems were accidentally
identifying people susceptible to
conspiratorial and reactionary thinking
and sending them increasingly deeper
into flat earth evangelism
and within that was just a quirk of good
timing i guess
the right cranks were churning out huge
volumes of low effort content
at just the right time for youtube to
prioritize it
and the moment it gained any traction at
all the system
reinforced that success but you know
let's keep some perspective here flat
earth for all the command it holds over
our collective interest
is still a very small movement the
largest flat earth channels cap out
around
150 000 subscribers with most coming in
well below that
and this is not much in the scope of
youtube where the opportunity cost of
subscription
is extremely low and for the last couple
years now
newer pro flat earth videos from these
channels have
mostly been skating by with a few
thousand views
in fact mark sargent the guy largely
credited with popularizing flat earth in
the youtube era
his videos used to get hundreds of
thousands of views
his seminal work flat earth clues has
1.1 million views
but he's only had two videos break six
digits since the start of 2018
one that's just a bootleg repost of
shane dawson's flat earth video
and one whinging about the last jedi
now youtube notably has made some
changes to the algorithm to prioritize
credible
sources which lowers the ranking of flat
earth videos
even within their own sphere but those
changes
were only implemented in early 2019 when
flat earth was
already on a downslope more impactfully
whether it's
debunking or merely profiling mainstream
channels talking
about flat earth from an external
perspective are just
vastly more popular than actual flat
earth content
so if you're watching flat earth videos
you are far
far more likely to be recommended
mainstream videos with
millions of views over evangelist videos
with hundreds
the bottom line is that flat earth has
been slowly bleeding support for the
last several years
because they're all going to cue anon
cuanon is a fascist biblical esoterics
apocalypse cult that believes an
anonymous government agent known only as
q is leaking sensitive above top secret
information
to patriots revealing that the political
and cultural opponents of donald j
trump the so-called deep state and
hollywood elite
are the minions of the cabal literal
satan worshiping pedophiles who kidnap
traffic molest and terrorize children in
order to produce and harvest
adrenochrome
a byproduct of the body processing
adrenaline which they use to get
high during their ritual worship of
their lord who is
again satan a constructed enemy so
cartoonishly evil that it justifies
discarding basically all human rights
in order to turn opposition to trump
into a crime in a sweeping authoritarian
purge of undesirables and political
opponents called
the storm that will usher in a golden
age of peace and prosperity or
the great awakening q has
put out there that many high-level
officials will soon be arrested
and it will actually be the drain the
swamp scenario that we have
we have always been wanting to happen he
says that once
once the corruption and the type of
corruption is revealed to the american
people
it will trigger something he calls the
awakening he says it will be like an
event
something that we've never witnessed in
american history
but it will it will cause americans to
unite
behind president trump in his
administration in order to completely
clean house
okay you guys if that happens we will be
so happy i see all those hearts and i
love it if that happens we will be so
happy
um i really truly pray that this is this
is true
and that's not even getting into the
co-morbid pizzagate myth of hidden
pedophile pizza shop sex dungeons that
has led many followers to see
any visual depiction of pizza the famous
and popular food
as subliminal code marking the outlines
of this vast conspiracy
look at this what's on his back yeah
look at that you see that instantly
appearing
so like if flat earth is simply anxious
for the end of the world
q kunan is a straight-up doomsday cult
except the form of their apocalypse is
less
divine and more secular with mass
arrests and in many versions public
executions
it's mostly just remixed takes on the
day of the rope from the 1978 neo-nazi
novel the turner diaries
also sometimes it's just literally the
day of the rope
because they're fascists if you're
unfamiliar with the turner diaries
this is a pretty effective summary the
novel told from the perspective of a
future activist
in the year 2099 outlines the diaries of
a revolutionary terrorist named earl
turner
in the distant future of the early 90s
it is in many respects the most hateful
book ever written
even though it's a distinctly american
conspiracy hinging specifically on
donald trump's presidency
q anon has found traction with far-right
and authoritarian movements worldwide
indeed a huge part of q's success can be
attributed to effective branding
the kind of instant recognition that
makes it appealing for groups worldwide
to just
localize and adapt q anon is pretty easy
to recognize around the internet and
in real life because similar to flat
earth there is a deeply evangelical
streak
they will share their beliefs
aggressively with just about everyone
and are big fans of branding things
marked with q
and q anon are pretty straightforward
but slightly more covert is their rally
in cry
where we go one we go all or wwg one wga
lifted from the 1996 film white squall
largo entertainment presents a film
about loyalty where we go one we go up
also in recent months q anon has been
aggressively colonizing hashtag save the
children
a fairly generic hashtag that's been in
use for years
but q anon has been taking over in order
to organize rallies and meetups that are
more likely to draw
in non-cue believers taking very real
cases of child abuse
and using them as the bridge to
introduce their entirely fictional cases
of child abuse and
the bulk of cue beliefs the messaging
here's so insidious
is that i'm for children and if you
don't come out here
you don't love children as much as i do
i think we're going to see a lot more of
this he doesn't lead with the pizzagate
stuff he doesn't lead with q anon he
leads with save the children and then
the pizzagate stuff has sort of slipped
underneath
well q anon originated in 2017 on 4chan
via cryptic
nonsensical anonymous post-moniker
q-drops
and even though new q-drops arrive
regularly on the 8-chan derivative
rebrand
8 [ __ ] q anon is at this point largely
self-sustaining via social media
q anon has become a haven for just about
every true believer in bizarre
conspiracies anti-science movements fad
diets and
the grifters who prey on them what's
called a big tent conspiracy
because virtually any other conspiracy
can fit inside it
this is as we discussed already
something of a feature of flat earth
many new age mystical and political
conspiracies are compatible with flat
earth
and q is that but bigger janet
ossibard's two and a half hour youtube
series fall of the cabal
which is in many ways to cue in on what
loose
change was to the 911 truth or
conspiracy
in both format and in function is mostly
just a collection of other
mostly racist conspiracies that she
claims are ultimately
q anon okay let's have a look at the
migrant caravan
do you realize that these four skins are
actually sold
president obama received the 2009 nobel
peace prize
only months after his inauguration why
for god's sake
he came from nowhere and had achieved
nothing at the time
hell even 911 trutherism is compatible
with q
9 11 whereas one bird can cause
terrible damage to a plane on 9 11
two planes managed to cut through steel
a third plane mysteriously disappeared
in a building
and number four plunged into the earth
without leaving
any debris or bodies the planes were
piloted by
terrorists who only had had a few flying
lessons in a small chestnut
see okay just a bit more groundwork
because that sounds silly q anon trusts
military intelligence and reveres
military might and shares a lot of pro
cop
thin blue line type sentiment while they
distrust the civilian intelligence
agencies now the standard 911 truther
conspiracy is that bush orchestrated 911
in order to create a crisis that would
allow him to implement the patriot act
create homeland security and justify a
couple wars
but q anon they imagine the patriot act
as a tool that trump is using to
dismantle the deep state and they love
homeland security because dhs is loyal
to trump
so the cue narrative of 911 focuses on
the pentagon
that bush was a cabal member who
orchestrated 911 in order to cover for a
precision missile attack on the pentagon
in an attempt at covering up cabal
activities
none of that makes sense don't try to
understand it through the lens of facts
it's all about loyalty one of the oft
discussed elements of these types of
groups is the way that fact-checking is
often used as a kind of filter
so if you sit down to watch assabar's
follow the cabal and you're the kind of
person who
is inclined to fact check and is curious
about the world and
is you know interested in thinking for
themselves and thinking about things
analytically and from a scientific
standpoint
you're probably not going to get very
far
into it because it comes out so fast and
so quick with things that are going to
make you like
pause and stop and like gather your
thoughts on explaining
why they're wrong first of all give you
a short overview of things that made me
go
hmm did you know that these fires forgot
to burn
trees that they were capable of cutting
through
houses like yes extremely
hot fast-moving fires will just
kind of burn through half a house that
they were able to
lift cars tilt them and smash them down
yeah that's what happens when the
gasoline
in the car's tank ignites and explodes
that they burn trees from the inside out
oh this is a really cool phenomenon
actually so if you have a tree that's
dead or has a weak spot in the bark or
has been attacked by certain types of
fungus
the interior of the tree uh gets exposed
and is potentially very dry and
much more flammable than the protective
bark on the outside of the tree
and so the fire is able to penetrate to
the interior of the tree and burn it
from the inside
out it's it's really cool and you're
turning it
into conspiratorial nonsense
things that made me go hmm a challenge
in making this
is that the q movement evolves very
quickly and is basically an ongoing
story
so it's impossible to give a summary of
the full scope that won't be
out of date as soon as the video goes
live not only that but
i have different dimensions of the
phenomenon that i want to focus on
so just know that i'm skipping hours and
hours and hours of discussion here
there's also a lot of stuff that we just
don't know for sure
like the identity of the actual person
or people
who write and post to the cue drops
there's some evidence that the original
q author was coleman rogers the founder
of patriot soapbox
and one of the first people to
popularize decoding as a social activity
in a 2018 nbc news profile of the
movement this claim is acknowledged and
supported by evidence like rogers
apparently logging into 8chan as
queue on stream or knowing about
authentic
cue drops that weren't posted with the q
account you know what
i got a question for you pam how come on
my system i don't get that picture
the google bike rack thing yeah
i it's not showing up on the um the q
post uh aggregator sites because q
posted
i think by accident as an anon but a lot
of that evidence was
poorly archived and has since been
deleted there's also a compelling
argument that the q account has changed
hands completely
at least once and many people believe
that jim watkins the owner of 8chan
or at least someone very close to
watkins is the current author of q
and has been since at least november
2019 when 8chan relaunched as eight koon
that relaunch represents a break in
continuity that makes it basically
impossible to verify one way
or the other with the information that
we have access to
and to a point it doesn't matter
whether or not rogers or watkins
are or were the anonymous authors of the
queue drops
they are publicly collaborators and
enablers of the movement
and benefit from it in money and
influence
so while i want to focus mainly on the
bigger picture
the underlying philosophical beliefs
that drive q and on
regardless of the specific form those
beliefs take
it would be irresponsible to not talk
about how this is manifesting in actual
actions
because ultimately these are the stakes
for example a notable subgroup that q
anon has drawn in
are unstable parents who are embroiled
in custody battles
sometimes pre-existing and sometimes as
a direct result of their involvement in
q anon driving their partners away
someone who's already on really shaky
emotional ground starts getting
super into q anon it's all they want to
talk about and they begin to fixate on
comorbid anti-vax conspiracies
or bleach treatment conspiracies and
they start giving their children bleach
or
put them on an all meat diet someone
either their partner or extended family
or child protective services
steps in these individuals believing
that they are in the right convince
themselves that the cabal
or the deep state has targeted them and
their children in retribution for
knowing too much the act of intervention
becomes further proof of their
correctness
because of course that's what the deep
state would do to protect their secrets
on june 11th 2020 alpolis slymon
attempted to kidnap his five children in
a mental
breakdown that led to a 110 mile per
hour chase with authorities that slim in
live streamed portions of to facebook
donald trump i need a miracle or
something somebody q and help me i'm
gonna help you
queue in and help me on july 2nd 2020
corey herron crashed a pickup truck
through the gates of one sussex drive
ottawa
the home of canada's governor general
and temporary residence of prime
minister justin trudeau
and stalked the grounds with a pistol
and rifle before being apprehended by
rcmp officers
shortly before the incident heron sent a
letter to his supervisor in the canadian
rangers claiming that he was motivated
to stop trudeau from turning canada into
a communist dictatorship
over the months prior hearn posted
various q anon
and general conspiracy memes to his
instagram account including
a white rabbit meme with the description
text has anyone else been following
q and the white rabbit down the rabbit
hole and how this all relates to the
coronavirus slash
covet 19 situation lots of coincidences
in all the q posts if this turns out to
be a nothing burger
hashtag q anon anons follow the white
rabbit adrenochrome adrenochrome
harvesting frazzle drip podesta emails
spirit cooking molech seth rich pedowood
pedogate pedovores pizzagate epstein
island pedo island
isaac cappy didn't kill himself these
people are sick
cabal where we go one we go all red pill
spygate deep state the storm
the storm is here the storm is upon us
trust the plan
coronavirus covet 19 coincidence
in june 2018 q anon believer matthew
wright barricaded the hoover dam bridge
with an armored truck for over an hour
demanding that authorities release the
oig report
a document that cue believers think
holds evidence of the thousands
of sealed indictments that they believe
trump's administration has filed against
cabal members
during the pandemic of the q anon
movement has been
appears to be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that and what you have to say to
people who are following this movement
right now well i don't know much about
the movement other than i understand
they like me very much
these are people that don't like seeing
what's going on in
places like portland and places like
chicago
and new york and other cities and states
and i've heard these are people that
love our country and they just don't
like seeing it
this is the radicalizing effect of cults
like q
it attracts and enables people with
personalities that are already inclined
towards these kind of actions and gives
them a reason to
take it further the reason the
fragmentary shoddy and contradictory
ideas of flat earth are so easy for most
adherents to accept
are because they're principally
interested in the broad strokes
and indeed the broad strokes are all
that matters
this is really easy to demonstrate for q
the gap filling that happens in between
is largely entertainment that keeps
people engaged
but rarely sticks long enough to form a
doctrinal pillar
for example the idea that the cabal is
harvesting adrenochrome
has been floating around in the queue
lore since late 2017
but only really surged in popularity in
and there's no guarantee that it'll last
even to the point that this video is
published q support for bleach drinking
and hydroxychloroquine as covid
treatments have stuck around reliably
for months but could be dropped any day
now and
followers wouldn't see any contradiction
in that at all the q lore is highly
unstable and extremely fluid
this is actually part of how people are
pulled in and kept engaged
as there's a soap opera or a-r-g-esque
immediacy
that brings people back day after day to
get
caught up on the latest developments the
latest theories and to all pitch in on
trying to decode the latest q-drop
which is the colloquial term for what
are effectively the beliefs foundational
texts
these q-drops and the smaller q-crumbs
are thousands of deliberately vague
messages
written in a mess of code words and
meaningless word salad
and it is then left to adherence to
unravel and establish
meaning by consensus so for example cue
drop 142 from november 12
2017 reads how did soros replace family
why who is family why
trace the bloodlines of these three
families what happened during world war
ii was hitler a puppet who was his
handler what was the purpose
what was the real purpose of the war
what age was gs
what is the soros family history what
has occurred since the fall of n germany
who is a merkel
what is a merkel's family history follow
the bloodline who died on the titanic
what year did the titanic sink
why is this relevant what exactly
happened to the titanic
what class of people were guaranteed a
lifeboat why did select
individuals not make it into the
lifeboats why is this relevant how do we
know who was on the lifeboats d
or a how were names and bodies recorded
back then when were tickets purchased
for her maiden voyage who
was specifically invited less than 10
what is the fed
what does the fed control who controls
the fed who approved the formation of
the fed
why did h would glorify titanic as a
tragic love story who lived in the movie
what man
why is this relevant opposite is true
what is brainwashing what is psyop what
happened to the hindenburg
what really happened to the hindenburg
who died during the
accident why is this relevant what are
sheep who controls the narrative the
truth would put 99 percent of people in
the hospital
it must be controlled snow white iron
eagle jason bourne cia
dream q what does that mean
honestly whatever the hell you want it
to mean or more accurately
whatever you need it to mean we are
we're past lm8 and we're coming up on
lm9
and the gosh i'm not
i haven't checked the i haven't checked
the map for
i haven't checked the map for exactly
where we are
uh but we're real close and i'm
looking off to the right now in just
every single one of these poplar trees
i'm thinking like oh could that be it is
that it is that the one
the official cue drops are verified on
the image boards by the use of a trip
code
a system that image boards use to show
that anonymous posts are coming from the
same user
or at least users who share the trip
code password
but ideas that gain traction in the
conspiracy don't even need to come from
the queue drops or be
implied by the queue drops the
adrenochrome conspiracy is kind of
a free radical idea that's been bouncing
around niche cultures for decades
and is essentially a remix of the
centuries-old anti-semitic conspiracy of
blood libel
but neither have ever been mentioned by
cue
in an official queue drop the less vague
cue predictions
citing specific dates and outcomes have
universally not come true
instead of detailing every single one
we'll just put a list on the screen
of all the dates that qanon said there
was going to be mass
arrests or some kind of exposure of
trump's enemies in the deep state
or just anything happening at all
only to have nothing happen but as with
most failed doomsday predictions
this isn't really a hang up because all
of that is just
sandwich filler to justify their support
for authoritarian policies directed at
people they already don't like
in fact one of the core anxieties from
the perspective of q anon
is that donald trump hasn't been
authoritarian enough
and the multi-layered deep state game of
4d chess is their explanation for why
he has not simply eliminated his enemies
and made america great again
likewise every failed q prediction
simply becomes reinforcing evidence
of just how powerful and thus dangerous
the mythological deep state really
is president trump and the entire q team
are working out a plan
that has been in the making for the past
20 years
a plan so all-encompassing it took this
long to calculate
every step every move to perfection
the dissonance of q is that the faithful
were supposed to be the beneficiaries of
trump's strongman nativist xenophobic
anti-progressive campaign
but they haven't because he's a selfish
grifter who used them for their
political convenience
and thus despite all his promises their
lives have generally gotten
materially worse under his criminal
presidency this is
emotionally psychologically a lot to
deal with and q
gives that disappointment shape and form
encouraging believers to
trust the plan it's deeply sad
and the increasingly convoluted
explanations for why
followers should discard their own
rational instincts and
trust the plan create a
self-radicalization cycle
one of the most insidious elements of a
confidence scam
is that the victims who invested the
most are often the most passionate
defenders
because shame is a powerful force in the
human psyche and they can't bear the
shame of admitting they were tricked
this results in q believers growing more
and more passionate
getting more and more involved and
further isolating themselves from others
particularly people who push back
against their evangelism
the end result is cue believers only
socializing
with other cue believers the covid
pandemic already a source of anxiety and
isolation for
virtually everyone has further
accelerated the process with the ranks
being bolstered by more and more people
who already subscribed to fringe medical
or conspiratorial beliefs
who are deeply unstable or who are just
generally amenable to authoritarianism
if they stand to benefit and of course
grifters
so so many grifters q
has managed to attract all the normal
types of grifters from policy hacks who
see the movement as a political body
that they can try to steer to either
bolster their own support or hurt their
opposition
to pundits who benefit from the traffic
cue brings in two quick buck drop
shippers to regular old con men
in fact whether you're looking to just
make some cash selling q branded
merchandise or if you want to build an
entire career on youtube as a queue
decoder
there's money to be made off q anon now
all this isn't to say that everyone's
either completely on board or a
full-blown grifter
that there aren't casual posters or that
people don't break out of these groups
a lot of people flirt with conspiracies
for periods of time because they're
entertaining they're exciting
the idea that the world is no more
complex than a long-running tv
show is appealing and it's fun to think
that there's somewhere you can go for a
narrator's eye view of reality there's
an emotional security
in believing that the world will only
ever be brought
to the dramatic edge of peril before a
clever twist saves the day
a lot of casual investigators dabble in
the fun and then bounce off after
run-ins with insufferable believers
disruptions like a website outage or
just getting distracted by a new video
game however this is a radicalization
pipeline and a lot of people
don't bounce off once they come across
something distasteful
people start with their generalized
sense of unease with the world
their undefined anxieties and a thing
like
q anon comes along with a lot of answers
bizarre answers inconsistent answers but
a lot of them
in every speech and every tweet he used
codes
for the q anons to pick up on he used
spelling errors such as kefafe instead
of coffee
referring to a new act about the saving
of all social media posts by the
president
they come in so fast and so confidently
that it's persuasive
it's not cohesive but there's so much of
it
as believers get more invested they
spend time decoding or watching others
decode and they become more accustomed
to integration and synthesization with q
anon this phase consists mostly of
constantly rearranging and rewriting
existing and evolving lore in order to
preserve desired outcomes and
gradually those outcomes the only thing
that remains consistent
become the fixed point in someone's life
that's the thing that q anon trains you
to do
to see specific outcomes the storm and
the great awakening
as the only thing that really matters
and everything else
is mutable q anon trains people to see
facts
as subservient to outcomes that facts
are just
game pieces you rearrange to justify
actions
this is how someone starts off with a
vague justified distrust of the
financial relationships between
elected officials and health insurance
companies and comes out the other end
believing that coronavirus is spread by
5g networks and the only solution is a
fascist crackdown on black lives matter
protesters and a war with china
increasingly one of the biggest reasons
why people leave q
is because they become frustrated with
the lack of results
and jump right into hardcore
accelerationist groups
this is something to be really worried
about because well
they're hardcore accelerationists and
it's the precursor to what's called
forcing the end this is where members of
a doomsday cult
disillusioned with the fact that
doomsday hasn't arrived
synthesized the belief that it's their
responsibility to create the
circumstances
that will allow doomsday to occur those
circumstances are almost always death
plague ecological collapse and societal
instability
and for people who have steeped
themselves in these ideas
that there is a foretold day of
reckoning that is directly
contingent on a specific man's access to
political power
and being told over and over and over
again to suppress
disillusionment with the lack of desired
results and
trust the plan it is a very small leap
to deciding that the plan all along was
q training them to be the instrument of
the storm
and now they need to take matters into
their own hands
we have this timeline here the mass
arrests they can't act too quickly
because they have to have certain assets
in place like judges you know other
countries have to be
ready to go because this is going to be
a global takedown and so and then you
have another window over here
where it's like it's they wait too long
and so we're in between this period of
too soon and too long before we make the
mass arrests and what's happening is
what the lord has shown me
is that if they wait too long which i
don't think they will but if they do
is that it could be another mogadishu or
another benghazi where the patriots will
rise up
and say enough's enough they will take
matters into their own hands and they
will drag their dead bodies through the
streets they will go to these
politicians houses or
offices and drag them out okay because
we again we want to pray against that
but i have to put that warning out there
i've been sitting on this for a year
because we're coming to the pinnacle
here where they're gonna have to act at
some point because the people are not
asking for justice they're demanding it
so the government has to act now if they
need to buy more time because they don't
have the assets in place
quite yet they need to make probably one
or two high-level arrests
high-profile arrests perp walk them on
national television
so that people will see that justice is
going to be done where i think
they've got to make the arrest before
january if they're going to make them
this year because if he arrests anyone
after january when campaign season
starts it's going to make it look like
he's just arresting those that oppose
him
coming at all this from the outside it's
really really easy to get frustrated
with q to get
frustrated talking about q or trying to
explain
q because there's so much noise in their
messaging so much
chaos that it's really easy to get hung
up on the sensational stuff
to fixate on the beliefs like
adrenochrome or the cabal
statues of moloch an expression of the
devil
are now watching over several american
cities
if you want to cut through the noise
it's this the unifying theme is a desire
for a sort of restorative
authoritarianism
for a strong man to come in and forcibly
put
everything back where it belongs
everything else is aesthetic
like flat earth there is a sympathetic
nugget in the anxiety
that the world has gotten too complex
that things are spinning out of control
but the q analysis of the problem is
that the fault lies
with the people outlining the complexity
the purpose of cosmologies like q like
flat earth
is to simplify the world and i know that
sounds ridiculous
the irony here is that this isn't all
that far off base
now not this specific example the q anon
map
of global politics is almost pure
nonsense
but the shape of it isn't if you were to
map out the political landscape of the
world
it would look a lot like this thousands
of political entities big and small all
with their own goals values and
incentives
navigating an equally complex series of
conflicts alliances and rivalries
in competition for power fame or limited
resources
so how is something like this making the
world
simpler because it takes all this
the chaos of millions of individuals
trying to reshape the world in their own
way for good or ill
and turns it into a single entity all
the world's complexity
all the chaos it's all the fault of one
group
not an ideology not a world view not
historical inertia
not anything so nebulous as the way we
think about the world
a single tangible identifiable group
with a written agenda
these types of conspiratorial beliefs
for all their complex cosmologies
exist in opposition to structural
challenges
and a lot of people get involved because
they resent
structural criticism structural
criticism poses
that we are the way we are because of
complicated forces
some intentional and many not that have
compounded
and morphed over generations there's no
plan
no template and no goal the world won't
just
magically morph into a better place as a
function of its existence
we are responsible for confronting the
past
fixing the present and shaping the
future q anon
and not just q anon many people many
many people
want to believe that things are the way
they are because someone has
deliberately crafted it to be that way
that there is a natural order to the
world and we need to just
trust the plan climate scientists trans
and queer activists women's rights
reproductive autonomy racial justice
protests against police brutality
generational wealth equality against the
increasing transfer of the public good
into the hands of corporations for
privatization and exploitation
all of these are interlocking systemic
issues
these are inarguably disruptions of the
status quo
confrontations of deep rooted
complexities that intersect the lives
and futures
of billions of people and it's that
disruption
not the underlying injustices not the
underlying conflicts
that make q anon anxious that make q
anon feel
like the world has gotten too complex
they don't want those complexities to
exist
and by talking about them you make them
it's a form of magical thought talking
about police brutality wills police
brutality into existence
a disruption of the status quo is seen
as a disruption of the natural order the
problem
they see is that no one has made those
people
shut up that is what they want someone
to come in
and make those people shut up and go
away to
put things back where they belong now
this is not a philosophy unique to qnon
it's the lifeblood
of all reactionary movements and they
are of course
in conflict with facts global warming to
pull one example
is real and an existential threat to
civilization
that's just a fact it wasn't wheeled
into existence by people talking about
it it isn't
overtuned leftist looking for patterns
in clouds it's the byproduct
of dumping carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere on an industrial scale for
200 years
and there is a temptation to engage on
that level to confront
all the material ways in which they are
just
wrong and it largely does not work
and what's unique about q anon is the
degree to which
it doesn't work the degree to which the
movement
is immune to evidence all reactionary
movements are in tension with reality a
tension that
eventually results in a psychological
crisis and belief systems like
q anon are the end point of that crisis
the point
where reality itself becomes an enemy
because ultimately it's not about facts
it's about power q anons are not
otherwise empty vessels who believe
one wacky thing they have an agenda
q anon what it accepts what it believes
is driven by the outcomes it justifies
the democratic national convention is
thinking about bringing bernie sanders
back
to run for president in 2020 can you
imagine
like what if he gets elected i seriously
hope not hopefully all this stuff goes
down
and there is an awakening and everyone
lines up behind president trump
i'm fed up with the attacks on president
trump i think he's the greatest
president
that we'll have in our lifetimes that
i'm grateful for all he's doing
and i'm proudly running for congress in
georgia's 14th district
the reason they aren't more bothered by
q constantly getting things wrong
why they aren't more bothered by the
extreme inconsistencies and outright
contradictions
by the claims that are just materially
wrong is because it gives them power
over others who are bound by something
as weak
and flimsy as reality they claim to be
against corruption while hanging their
hopes on an openly corrupt man
and that naked hypocrisy is the point
they will effortlessly carve out an
exception
because it makes them exceptional they
engage in wild hypocrisy
as an act of domination adhering to
something demonstrably untrue
out of spite because they believe that
power
belongs to those with the greatest will
to take it and what greater sign of will
than the ability to override truth
their will is a hammer that they are
using to beat reality
itself into a shape of their choosing a
simple world
where reality is exactly what it looks
like through their eyes
devoid of complexity devoid of change
where they are right and their enemies
are silent
they are trying to build a flat earth
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you